[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux
devenu une des principales sources
d'information ils sont aussi un
instrument de manipulation politique et
joue un rôle de plus en plus important
dans les relations internationales
alors quels sont les enjeux
géopolitiques autour des réseaux sociaux
la façon dont les réseaux sociaux
procède à la modération de leurs
contenus suscite des questions et des
accusations de politisation d'un côté
facebook et twitter supprime en masse
des comptes dans plusieurs pays
diffusant des messages pro
gouvernementaux et de l'autre il
n'hésite pas non plus à bloquer
certaines publications allant à
l'encontre de la politique de washington
le 28 mai dernier le président américain
signe un décret visant à limiter la
protection des réseaux sociaux
en vertu de ce document tous les
avantages juridiques offertes aux
plateformes en ligne seront désormais
réexaminer ce qui a fait perdre patience
à donald trump c'est la mention vérifier
les faits placé par twitter sous deux de
ces messages polémique
il n'a pas digéré cette intervention
très politique de twitter dans la
communication présidentielle et veut
depuis mettre un tour de vis aux gaffes
qui jouissait jusqu'à l'art de
privilèges spécifiques
désormais c'est d'ailleurs une tendance
la régulation gouvernementale des
réseaux se renforce dans beaucoup de
pays occidentaux
un exemple récent en est la loi avia en
france ou encore des projets similaires
au royaume uni pourtant de nombreuses
associations comme la quadrature du net
lutte activement contre le contrôle des
réseaux sociaux en dénonçant les risques
de sur censure
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur l'usagé des réseaux
sociaux à travers le monde
c'est le blitz à l'échelle mondiale
l'utilisation des plateformes en ligne
augmente sans cesse selon le dernier
rapport digitale globale overview de
2020 à peu près la moitié de la
population mondiale se servent des
réseaux sociaux soit 3 8 milliards de
personnes un utilisateur moyen il passe
deux heures et 24 minutes par jour le
réseau social le plus populaire reste
beloin facebook qui compte près de 2,4
milliards d'utilisateurs actifs chaque
mois
la plateforme de mark zuckerberg est
talonné par youtube avec ses 2 milliards
d'utilisateurs mensuels dernier dans le
top 3 le rival chinois
oui chat comptabilise plus de 1,1
milliard d'utilisateurs à ce jour plus
qu'un simple moyen de communication les
réseaux sociaux s'imposent de plus en
plus comme un puissant outil d'influencé
politique un simple tweet ou une
publication sur facebook peut faire
flamber les cours sur le marché mondial
où provoqué un scandale diplomatique les
plateformes en ligne sont souvent le
point de départ des mobilisations de
masse des mouvements de protestation ou
encore de la propagation de contenu
illégal
face à ce phénomène un nombre
grandissant d'états entendent renforcer
leur contrôle sur les réseaux sociaux
un des pionniers dans ce domaine
l'allemagne adopte en 2017 une nouvelle
loi de régulation des réseaux sociaux et
en france la loi avia adopté en 2020
élargit les pouvoirs du csa sur la
régulation des contenus sur internet
même aux états unis où les réseaux
sociaux bénéficient d'une protection
juridique et n'arme des voix se lèvent
pour renforcer le contrôle de l'état fin
mai 2020 donald ram fait le premier pas
vers un réexamen de la loi qui exonère
les plateformes en ligne de toute
responsabilité pour leur contenu
cependant toutes ces initiatives sont
critiquées par de nombreuses
associations et ong qui luttent contre
le contrôle excessif que ce soit de la
part des états ou des plateformes en
ligne elle-même car l'impartialité de
ces dernières est souvent mise en doute
de la suppression des publications
soutien au général iranien suleimani au
blocage des comptes de l' agence
d'information russe poutine
les cas sont nombreux quels sont les
critères de modération appliquée par les
réseaux sociaux quelle est leur
importance sur le plan géopolitique
enfin quelles régulations les états à
adopter t-il sur l'activité des
plateformes en ligne pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons fabrice
epelboin enseignant à sciences po
spécialiste des réseaux sociaux
monsieur le pm - bonjour bonjour pensez
vous que l'importance des réseaux
sociaux dans la lutte politique et
médiatique et déjà comparable à celle
des médias traditionnels
je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse faire une
comparaison en fait parce que ce qui se
passe c'est que ces trente dernières
années
le dispositif médiatique 1 est partie de
quelque chose ou les médias contrôler la
distribution de l'information
on a cheminé à journal on émettait une
émission de télévision à un monde dans
lequel un l'acheminement de
l'information est de plus en plus dans
les mains des réseaux sociaux et on est
en train de s'apercevoir que l'
influence c'est à dire toute la
possibilité d' interférence dans
l'opinion publique
finalement est plus du ressort du tuyau
qui acheminent informations que des
producteurs d'information donc on a en
fait cette influence du xxème siècle
était le système médiatique dans son
ensemble est pourquoi pas le système
politique qui est adossé à ce stade
médiatique qui tout d'un coup doit faire
place à un nouvel acteur qui sont les
tuyaux kirghize tout cela au citoyen et
ses nouveaux acteurs effectivement c'est
les réseaux sociaux essentiellement
facebook donc on est dans une transition
de la comparaison est difficile parce
que c'est une
c'est un nouvel entrant par rapport à un
vieux système qui est toujours là mais
qui commence à réaliser que produire de
l'information ça n'est pas si
stratégique que ça ce qui est important
c'est l'acheminement de cette
information à la bonne personne
pensez vous que ce soit bon pour la
diplomatie
par exemple un simple tweet de donald
trump puisse influencer de manière
considérable la politique ou l'économie
mondiale est désormais à cela que
ressemble la diplomatie moderne
alors dieu merci pour l'instant les
usages tels que donald trump
sont pas extrêmement répondu non plus
parmi les chefs d'état mais il n'est pas
le seul à avoir ce petit busage ensuite
la diplomatie heureusement c'est avant
tout des dizaines de milliers de
diplomates qui travaillent dans l'ombre
et que c'est un métier par nature très
discrète et qui dieu merci arrive à
faire tenir encore un peu le monde c'est
cellule intervention donald trump dans
le champ diplomatique en relation
directe avec notamment la population de
sa population mais le monde entier
change pas mal les choses un brusque
énormément les choses accélère sans
doute beaucoup de choses mais on n'en
est pas encore à une redéfinition totale
du champ diplomatique à travers les
baies compte twitter de quelques
dirigeants
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup des
guerres d'informations entre différentes
pays sur les réseaux sociaux
pourtant peut-on vraiment gagner une
telle guerre sachant que les réseaux
sociaux les plus influents aujourd'hui
appartiennent aux américains ah oui tout
à fait si on sait ce qu'on est en train
de faire si on sait instrumentaliser les
réseaux sociaux instrumentaliser ces
algorithmes qui ont une tendance
naturelle à fragmenter l'opinion et a
polarisé l'opinion publique il appelle
n'y a pas de besoin de posséder les
réseaux sociaux pour avoir une influence
à travers les socios il ya de très
nombreuses nations à commencer par la
russie qui vont utiliser facebook pour
allaient impacter l'opinion publique
d'un pays étranger c'est que c'est un
sport qui est assez courant depuis cinq
ans et on pourront retrouver les
origines pour ce qui est des réseaux
sociaux
il ya déjà une dizaine d'années donc
c'est quelque chose de très répandu au
monde
merci beaucoup monsieur epelboin nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons en fin
d'émission pour plus de détails sur la
question merci le 11 juin 2000 28 heures
annonce le blocage de milliers de
comptes dans plusieurs pays en cause
leurs contenus jugés trop pro
gouvernementales par le réseau social
23 1750 conte chinois sont supprimées
pour propagande du parti communiste
chinois et fausses informations sur la
vie politique
à hong kong en turquie twitter procès de
blocage de 7340 compte pour diffusion
des messages de soutien à la cape et et
d'opinions favorables au président r
douanes
twitter a également supprimé une série
de coups
en provenance de russie qui diffusait
des messages pro russe la suppression
massive de ponte est également effectuée
par facebook
en juillet le réseau social bloc des
dizaines de comptes supposément liées au
président brésilien jaillir ball sonar
où il publiait des nouvelles et des
annonces critiquant l'opposition mais il
n'ya pas que l'information pro
gouvernementales ou jugées tendancieuses
par facebook qui peut connaître la
censure celle qui va à l'encontre des
intérêts de washington subit parfois le
même sort exemple en janvier 2020
facebook supprime des publications en
hommage au général iranien
soleimani qui venait d'être liquidée par
une frappe américaine
la raison évoquée est alors les
sanctions américaines imposées en raison
de l'activité de soleimani qualifié de
terroriste par les états unis
un an plus tôt la plateforme de mark
zuckerberg qui supprime 289 groupes et
75 comptes ayant un lien supposé avec
les agences de presse russes spoutnik
selon facebook la décision est largement
due à leur contenu nous avons constaté
que ces pages et ses comptes étaient
liés à des employés de spoutnik et que
certaines des pages publiées fréquemment
sur des sujets tels que le sentiment
anti otan les mouvements de protestation
et la lutte contre la corruption
politisation ou pas quoi qu'il en soit
les réseaux sociaux sont souvent
utilisés à des fins politiques un des
exemples les plus connus et la
révolution tunisienne des tweets et
statuts antigouvernementaux témoignages
et informations en temps réel le réseau
social a vite propagé la contestation
populaire qui a abouti à la chute du
président ben ali en janvier 2011
c'est à ce même moment que les
plateformes sociales ont tourné à plein
régime pour mobiliser des milliers de
manifestants sur la place tahrir au
caire après les révoltes populaires en
tunisie et en egypte c'était au tour de
la libye de s'enflammer
mi février les opposants libyens ont
invité à travers facebook la population
à descendre dans les rues
à l'échelle mondiale de plus en plus
d'états recours au blocage des réseaux
sociaux pendant les bouleversements
politiques élections et référendums ou
manifestations de masse selon le dernier
rapport de l'oms
cessna rien qu'en 2010 9 38 blocage des
réseaux sociaux ont été enregistrés à
travers le monde
ils portent tous un caractère temporaire
de quelques heures à quelques mois mais
il arrive parfois que le blocage
devienne définitif comme c'est le cas en
chine en juillet 2009 les autorités
chinoises les mythes l'accès à facebook
la décision fait suite à de sanglants
affrontements inter ethniques dans la
région autonome ouïghoure
selon pékin facebook était un maillon
important dans le réseau de
communication eau des militants
indépendantistes en 2014
c'est au tour d'instagram d'être bloqués
en cause la diffusion des milliers de
photos en soutien à des manifestations à
hong kong
ces plateformes de communication et de
diffusion de l'information deviennent
petit à petit des pièces maîtresses de
différentes campagnes électorales à
travers le monde
c'est le cas notamment du président
tunisien kaïs sayed qui remporte les
élections présidentielles en octobre
ancien professeur de droit il est très
populaire chez les jeunes environ 90 %
ont voté pour lui la raison en est une
active campagne sur les réseaux sociaux
menés par les volontaires l'autre
candidat qui a pleinement profité des
réseaux sociaux et le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky comédien
est novice en politique et le pied en
avril 2019 le meilleur score jamais
enregistré dans l'histoire du pays
73 % à la différence de ses adversaires
il choisi une stratégie de communication
directe avec ses électeurs en menant
quasi exclusivement sa campagne sur
facebook et instagram
les réseaux sociaux ont également joué
un rôle important dans l'élection du
président américain donald trump plus
actif sur twitter et facebook ayant plus
d'abonnés que ses adversaires comme
hillary clinton par exemple hélas
largement profité de cette audience pour
être élue je doute que je serai ici sont
les réseaux sociaux pour être honnête
avec vous
la diplomatie du tweet apparu sous l'ère
obama continue à prospérer sous donald
trump les grands de ce monde rejoignent
de plus en plus activement les grandes
plateformes sociales qui deviennent pour
eux un nouveau terrain d'affluence selon
la dernière étude de tweeples sommes à 6
95% des gouvernements et des dirigeants
dans le monde
sont présents sur les plates formes en
ligne déclaration politique qui appelait
le dialogue ou menacent une seule
publication ou un tweet peut déclencher
des changements profonds sur la scène
internationale ou bouleverser les
marchés mondiaux en avril 2020 il a
suffi d'un seul tweet de donald trump
pour faire repartir les cours du brut
qui ont augmenté de 47%
le président américain a annoncé une
baisse de la production d'environ 10
millions de barils
évoquant un accord entre la russie et
l'arabie saoudite
alors quel chemin les réseaux sociaux
août il parcourut de simples moyens de
communication à outils politiques
importants comment sont ils utilisés
dans les batailles diplomatiques quelles
sont les mesures envisagées par les
gouvernements afin de réguler l'activité
des plateformes en ligne
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
de plus en plus populaire et accessible
à travers le monde
les réseaux sociaux sont un milieu idéal
pour transmettre rapidement des messages
vous tentez des manipulations et parfois
au plus haut niveau
la naissance des premiers réseaux
sociaux da des années 90 oubliée depuis
pour la plupart des sites comme
classmate ou six de guise ont préfiguré
l'aspect de ces services
aujourd'hui le véritable essor commence
pourtant au début des années 2000 avec
l'apparition des sites tels que myspace
ou linkedin facebook youtube et twitter
pour n'en citer que quelques-uns leur
concept alors nouveau et attrayant
s'aligne avec la généralisation des
ordinateurs et d'internet sur tous les
continents et captivent le public
le nombre d'utilisateurs de réseaux
sociaux montent en flèche de quelques
lignes ont ils évolué jusqu'à 3,8
milliards en 2018
au total c'est donc près de la moitié de
la population mondiale qui utilisent les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui leur chiffre
d'affaires ne cesse de grimper
entre 2010 et 2019 youtube passe de 825
millions à 15,1 milliards de dollars en
revenus annuels bond fulgurant aussi
pour twitter qui passe de 28,2 millions
à 3,4 milliards ainsi que pour le réseau
professionnel linkedin de 243,1 millions
à 6,8 milliards de dollars quant au
numéro un des géants sociaux facebook
son chiffre d'affaires monte en flèche
de 1,9 milliard de dollars en 2009 à
55,8 milliards en 2018
son nombre d'employés quant à lui est
presque multiplié par dix en à peine 10
ans les résultats impressionnants que le
réseau le plus populaire doit à son
modèle économique
sa principale source de revenus et la
vente de publicité avec un avantage
crucial
elles sont ciblées sur le public pré
sélectionnés en fonction de ses intérêts
les intérêts déterminé par facebook l'ia
des données personnelles et des
empreintes numériques des utilisateurs
qu'ils collectent une pratique qui est
longtemps resté opaque voire inconnus au
grand public et qui n'a été révélé
qu'après de nombreux scandales celui de
cambridge analytica en 2018 a le plus
fait parler
en effet les données de 87 millions
d'utilisateurs facebook ont été
collectés à leur insu par une
application tierce puis transmises à un
cabinet d'analystes politiques
ce dernier en a profité pour influencer
l'opinion publique lors des élections
présidentielles américaines de 2016
facebook doit alors payer une amende
record de 5 milliards de dollars aux
états unis et des centaines de millions
dans d'autres pays pour sa mauvaise
gestion des données privées de ses
utilisateurs les réseaux sociaux se sont
révélées être le moyen le plus efficace
pour les pme d'atteindre un plus large
public et par conséquent de créer des
emplois en effet dans une étude 2020
effectué par copenhague and economics
est sponsorisé par facebook
près de 8000 entreprises européennes ont
révélé que le groupe de mark zuckerberg
leur a permis de réaliser en 2010 9 des
ventes estimées à 2 108 milliards
d'euros et aurait contribué à créer plus
de trois millions d'emplois en europe
en plus de leur importance dans le
secteur économique les réseaux sociaux
peuvent se vanter d'être devenu une des
principales sources d'information chez
les utilisateurs en effet selon une
étude 2018 du centre de recherche pew
aux etats unis un adulte sur cinq
s'informent régulièrement via les
réseaux sociaux soit 20% une popularité
et ce malgré le fait que certains
réseaux sociaux tels que twitter et
facebook ont été accusés de propager de
fausses informations notamment lors de
la campagne électorale américaine de
2007 selon une étude de l'université
d'oxford en 2019 des campagnes de
manipulation sur les réseaux sociaux ont
été organisées dans 70 pays
leurs auteurs sont des agences
gouvernementales des partis politiques
des sociétés privées ou des groupes
d'activisme ciblant le public à domicile
ils cherchent en amplifier ou a étouffé
certains sujets opinion ou encore à
discret
it et l'opposition sur internet en
utilisant des bottes ou bien des
employés réel le rapport pointe du doigt
surtout les autorités des pays
développés ou en voie de développement
de la russie et la chine jusque au
royaume uni et les etats unis ce que le
rapport qualifie de propagande numérique
ne se limite évidemment pas à des
opérations à l'intérieur le blocus
diplomatiques commerciales et terrestre
du qatar en 2017 en est un récent
exemple ses initiateurs les pays du
golfe tels que l'arabie saoudite et les
émirats arabes unis cherchent alors le
soutien de washington pour l'heure des
marques et pour l'obtenir à coup sûr il
entame une campagne sur les réseaux
sociaux pour influencer l'opinion
publique américaine sur le qatar des
comptes diffusant en masse des
informations négatives sur doha des
promotions payer sur facebook twitter et
youtube
des filtres snapshot les moyens sont là
et pour se réhabiliter le qatar répond
par la réciproque ils déploient des
contre-mesures sur toutes les
plateformes utilisées par ses rivaux
dans cette guerre d'information quelle
est la responsabilité des plateformes
elle-même que font-elles pour endiguer
ces opérations eh bien les géants du web
n'acceptent pas facilement d'assumer
leurs responsabilités pour les contenus
qu'ils abritent
le problème se cache dans la législation
américaine et enlève aux réseaux sociaux
toute responsabilité pour les contenus
postés par les utilisateurs
c'est sur cette loi que ça puis facebook
twitter ou encore youtube société
américaine pourtant les scandales comme
l'a prétendu ingérence dans les
élections américaines de 2016 tous les
géants du web à mieux repérer et
éliminer les contenus haineux violent ou
encore les fakes news
de plus en plus active leur lutte se
fait cependant selon leurs propres
conditions
en supprimant les publications les
réseaux sociaux aussi surtout des
infractions aux valeurs de la communauté
ou à la politique du site souvent
formulée très vaguement contrôle total
sur les contenus et reddition de compte
limiter liberté que donald trump se
prépare à réduire en 2020 les tensions
entre twitter et le chef d'état
eric un monte d'un cran le réseau appose
une mention du risque de désinformation
sur un tweet de 30
le président américain évidemment
s'insurge contre la censure en ligne et
lance une action légale fin mais donald
trump
si un décret pour amender la fameuse
section 230 qui exonère les sites de
toute responsabilité
désormais la voie est ouverte à des
poursuites judiciaires contre les
réseaux pour leurs abus supposés pour
compléter la transformation il faut
pourtant que ces changements passent par
le congrès en attendant d'autres sites
rejoindre la bataille rééditer youtube
blogs des centaines de comptes associés
à 30 tandis que twitch supprime
certaines de ses propres vidéos le tout
pour un pot logis de la violence ou de
laine
on ignore encore quelle sera l'issue de
ce bras de fer entre temps en dehors des
états unis
le manque d'eau contrôler les abus
fréquents des plateformes américaines
inquiètent aussi de plus en plus
l'europe par exemple cherchent à se
réserver le dernier mot et multiplie des
initiatives légales pour réguler ces
sites sur les réseaux sociaux la
tolérance envers les incitations aux
actes criminels doit être aussi limité
que dans la rue l'allemagne est une des
pionnières dans ce domaine depuis 2018
une loi baptisée net dg oblige les
réseaux sociaux de plus de 2 millions
d'utilisateurs de supprimer rapidement
des contenus légaux sous peine d'une
lourde amende 50 millions d'euros en
france
une législation similaire la fameuse loi
avia a récemment été adopté
elle s'étend d'ailleurs en moteurs de
recherche aux blogs et aux forums et en
grande bretagne
la fonction de contrôle sur les réseaux
sociaux sera bientôt accorder au
régulateur de l'audiovisuel ofcom en
plus de la presse de la radio et de la
télé il va veiller à la légalité des
contenus partagés sur les réseaux et
sanctionner les sites si nécessaire au
niveau européen de telles lois
n'existent pas encore seul initiative
similaire le code de conduite proposé
par la commission européenne en 2016 et
signé depuis par toutes les plateformes
principales respectée dans ses grandes
lignes ce code barre est non
contraignant une
acune que l'union européenne se prépare
à combler fin 2020 avec le digital
services act il est essentiel de
renforcer et de moderniser les règles
applicables aux services numériques dans
l'ensemble de l'union européenne
en clarifiant le rôle et les
responsabilités des plateformes en ligne
avec cette loi l'europe veut établir un
standard mondial dans la lutte contre
les contenus illégaux mais aussi les
comportements offensif les manipulations
et les fausses informations sur les
réseaux sociaux
pourtant cette volonté d'apparence
bénéfique inquiète plusieurs
associations qui luttent contre le sur
contrôle des réseaux sociaux que ce soit
de la part des états ou des plateformes
elle-même en france et en europe c'est
la quadrature du net qui est le groupe
le plus dynamique dans ce combat c'est
cible la plus récente et notamment la
loi avia dont le texte selon
l'association limite la liberté
d'expression en laissant les acteurs
privés et juger ce qui est admissible ou
non
l'autre risque est là sur censure de
peur d'une amende colossale les
plateformes peuvent supprimer des propos
parfaitement légaux pourtant la
quadrature du net c'est fait aussi
connaître pour sa défense des
utilisateurs
il y a deux ans elle a lancé une
procédure collective contre les gars
femme pour avoir exploité les données
personnelles des européens
résultat de cette action google a déjà
écopé d'une amende de 50 millions
d'euros
l enquête sur les autres plateformes est
toujours en cours pour mieux comprendre
comment le numérique et la géopolitique
se mêlent nous revenons vers fabrice
epelboin enseignant à sciences po et
spécialiste des réseaux sociaux
monsieur penguin continuons avec les
guerres d'information pensez vous que la
décision de la chine de bannir les
réseaux sociaux comme facebook ou
twitter est en fait une mesure efficace
pour résister à ce type de guerre
extrêmement efficace et pas que pour ça
la grande muraille de chine peut être
vue de deux façons la grande muraille
numérique du film ce grand firewall
produite de façon c'est une façon
d'éviter que les citoyens chinois aient
accès à de l'information dont le
gouvernement chinois que le gouvernement
chinois veut censurer mais c'est aussi
une façon de protéger tout
un écosystème la chine a ses propres
gaffe à la chine est totalement ou
presque totalement souveraine dans son
environnement numérique et il ya très
peu de nations sur terre qui peuvent
prétendre à sa souveraineté
non en grande partie la chine voit ça
vous fait d'avoir des départs développer
son propre internet et on serre contre
son propre internet d'une véritable
muraille ces dernières années de plus en
plus de pays renforcent leur régulation
des réseaux sociaux
pourquoi cette tendance se manifeste
elle surtout un récemment elle se
manifeste parce que la prise de
conscience par le personnel politique en
france comme ailleurs qu'il ya réel
problème est qu'il ya une porosité
entrée en matière d' influence qui est
né de ces stupidités des réseaux sociaux
et cette internalisation des réseaux
sociaux tels que le personnel politique
se saisit du problème il n'a pas encore
les capacités à le caractérise et à
l'analyse et de passion a éventuellement
apporter des solutions mais à défaut ils
commencent à légiférer
c'est pas la première fois que des
politiques qui ne comprennent pas un
problème légifère dessus se souvient
pour les plus âgés d'entre nous d'hadopi
et il va arriver à un moment ou un autre
les politiques arrivent mans à
comprendre la nature du problème de
façon à pouvoir éventuellement envisager
de légiférer de façon efficace pour
l'instant on est dans la première étape
qui consiste à tout simplement essayé de
mettre en place des censures ce qui est
dans des démocraties occidentales est
très compliqué très compliqué d'une part
parce que ces systèmes ne sont pas
vraiment pensé pour être censuré parce
que l'application de la justice
industrialisés pour sa réel problème
démocratique
et puis très compliqué parce que
vis-à-vis de l'opinion publique la
censure n'est pas quelque chose de très
compatible avec la démocratie
donc on s'attaque à la confiance envers
les gouvernants ou s'attaque aux
sentiments de démocratie et ça ça peut
avoir des effets absolument dramatique
donc à partir du moment où c'est pas
tout à fait bien et c'est pas tout à
fait envisageable aujourd'hui les
réseaux sociaux selon vous peuvent-ils
s'autoréguler l'autorégulation ça
implique que les individus qui sont les
acteurs de ces réseaux sociaux en soit
réellement les acteurs et soient maîtres
de mettre en place une forme
d'autorégulation collectif c'est pas du
tout ce qui se passe
vous n'êtes pas un acteur si le facebook
vous êtes un
et vous êtes un produit que facebook ou
vend à des annonceurs que ce soit des
marchands de soupe un ou des politiques
vous restez un produit et les acteurs
sont les algorithmes qui oriente en tout
ces flux sociaux tous ces flux
d'informations donc il n'y a pas
d'autorégulation possible il les a déjà
une régulation à travers des adwords est
impacté cette régulation des algorithmes
pour la rendre compatible avec un climat
politique un environnement législatif
qui ont plus barrés d'une frontière à
l'autre dans un système qui est
totalement globale sur facebook qui a
pas de frontières vous pouvez discuter
avec un belge ou un américain très
concrètement où a lieu cette discussion
est quelque chose que le droit ne peut
pas car est captée par exemple donc tout
ça pose d'énormes problèmes
mais pour revenir à l'autorégulation ça
n'est pas possible la régulation sur
facebook elle est le fait d'algorithmes
et ses facebook qui régule facebook sur
ce pronostic
merci beaucoup fabrice epelboin je
rappelle vous êtes enseignant à sciences
po et spécialiste des réseaux sociaux
merci beaucoup
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt francs
[Musique]